scientists are overwhelmingly atheistic
in nature why do you think that is why
is there this apparent massive gap
between the practice of science and
belief in religion I think many
scientists fall back in this Trope that
you know I'd rather have questions that
cannot be answered than answers that
cannot be questioned as you know the
word Israel and Hebrew means someone who
fights with God a people that argues
with God and we are being tested in some
ways and it's difficult I mean the
question of theodicy is you've gone over
that many times but in particular I
think scientists have a natural
anti-authoritarianism that they don't
like to be told what to do I think that
they oftentimes biggest atheists you
know that I know have sort of a very
simplistic understanding of religion and
so it's very easy to prop up a straw man
straw woman as we would say and then
tear it down burn it up because in
reality that's just another form of
instead of anti-authority bias it's a
form of confirmation bison
[Music]